Last couple of years.
Calm has been interesting.
It was a lot of people that are fans of Donald Trump.
A lot of people that aren't fans of Donald Trump.
And I think it's petty for you to be upset with anybody because they chose to
vote for whoever they chose to vote for.
I think it's stupid shit.
But I will say this past election was interesting in the sense that a lot of
people were upset.
Black people were upset the last election.
Uh,
when we're upset,
gay people were upset,
but white people were really upset.
Like white people were the angriest and white people did not protest.
They voted.
Black people was like,
black lives matter white people.
It's like we'll see about that in the morning and when ever you hear someone
says,
we'll see about that in the morning.
It's going to be some change.
But comedy,
I don't think kindness should be a place where people exercise anger or be
angry.
How so?
In what way?
That,
um,
like p and Matt,
like when Donald Trump first got elected,
you know,
personally like it,
it was very interested in,
and I seen a lot of comics,
they could just go up there and be like,
Fuck Donald Trump and just,
ah,
you know,
you could find a way to say fuck Donald Trump or anybody,
but it doesn't have to be fueled with any anger.
You know what I'm saying?
It doesn't have to be fueled.
Like fuck.
You'd be like,
fuck them.
Okay.
Why?
Why do you say that?
Why do you say funnel?
And then loud the reason,
but I just don't think that people should be angry about how you feel about
fine.
I think it's fucked up when politics made people
angry.
It's it contrary to what you were saying was great about Chappelle show that the
comedy came without being angry,
but it made great points,
but even anybody on both sides could laugh at it.
Yeah.
The thing about Trump that's,
it's interesting,
it's like
the job shouldn't exist.
The job of web president,
yes.
It shouldn't exist.
It's a ridiculous idea to have 300 million people under the guidance of one.
That's insane.
And that one's,
that one wins in a popularity contest.
That's insane.
Right?
It's fucking insane.
It doesn't make sense.
It was a,
it was a great idea back when they were pilgrims and it was a small colony and
they just came over on a boat.
Forget it.
Forget about the rest of this shit.
It's just too many humans.
So when you let a guy like that,
like try to be president,
no,
he,
you're not going to be happy.
No one's going to be happy.
Right,
but you're not going to be happy if anybody wins.
It's,
it's,
it's untenable.
Look at Obama,
Obama aged like how many of years in eight years he looked at yoga.
They all do that.
It's like Ted Danson effect once.
Cheers.
Got Counseling.
Who the fuck is that?
You're the first time you saw Ted desert.
I'm not talking about years after two years.
Like after Fred.
You like God damn.
Stop dying his hair.
Yeah.
Yeah,
man.
Is there something about Trump before that that people enjoy that he was in a
lot of rap lyrics.
He was like the like people would probably still be if he was a rapper's to have
resident right now,
it'd be different.
He still be popular.
People wrap the bottom.
They liked that lifestyle.
But the thing was to just my thoughts.
The thing was because you thought
you knew a person,
you thought,
you know,
but even when he got elected,
I think a lot of people thought they knew him.
Right?
They thought they knew him.
They thought the image.
Like you ain't gonna be the billion.
Got Billion dollar playboy GAF ever.
But you thought you knew him.
But then when you got to know him,
you start to think,
well,
maybe I didn't know him when you got to see him as president.
Yeah.
You get,
I'm saying like,
I don't think even as even as much as even how he got elected,
people were upset about it,
but I think a lot of people,
somebody was like,
did you know what?
Maybe all of that shit was just to get elected.
Maybe that energy was to get elected and if that was the case that he'd mastered
it,
he'd mastered how to get connected with his base.
He Massad Ma,
he mastered how to get,
not everybody the fuck would you put just the right amount of people?
Yeah,
he looked at the numbers.
It wasn't about them.
It was a popularity contest,
but it's also a new,
like these are the people that got hit and he figured that out.
Did I think at some point Joe people were like,
hi,
okay,
it's over now.
Let's see who you really are.
And I think it's so many examples of when you felt like he could showed people
example,
example that he's fought.
Everybody opposed the judge just as base.
Right.
And I think that's what gets people ladder.
What make people frustrated.
He gives impression that,
you know,
I only care about these people that elected me.
You won.
Right?
But do you have responsibility to everybody?
And it's just don't have that felony.
Even on my social media,
I don't go hard.
I keep it kind of neutral.
But I said something and somebody said,
well,
the last time I checked on hill,
the economy was doing well.
And I said,
ah,
you can't confuse the economy with humanity.
And that's the thing.
And that's what,
that's what people don't feel good about.
You can tout all the numbers,
you could talk all the numbers,
you want a black unemployment,
all the numbers,
all the numbers.
But how do people feel?
You know what I'm saying?
The representative,
they don't feel,
don't,
they don't feel represented.
Don't,
they don't feel like I can rock either way,
but I'd Democrat,
Republican,
I'm making enough money where a lot of the views of Republicans be Joe,
that's right up
my alley.
You know what I'm saying?
How you got there,
right.
I'm ready.
Are,
you know,
like damn,
I fucked a Republican business before this.
You know what I'm saying?
You don't have to say it,
but at same time,
it's the,
and it may not sound right to a lot of people,
but it's the human factor of it.
You know what I'm saying?
Like you want to feel good,
right?
You want to you why so many people don't know the economy is doing well because
they don't feel good.
You know what I'm saying?
You want to celebrate,
you want to cheer,
you want to feel good about it.
And that's the whole thing.
Anything.
I believe when Obama ran like his campaign was change,
Donald Trump will make America great again.
Either one of them could have ran off each other's campaign slogan.
Do you know after Bush Obama could have said make American great again and it
would electrify the debase the same as change.
True.
They said the same fucking thing.
That would be a great thing for Obama.
And I'm gonna tell you one thing that kind of insulting or are we get people
upset.
It's like you keep pushing a narrative,
make America great again.
Make America great again.
You keep pushing that as if America was so fucked up before you took office.
And that's not the case.
Like when,
when,
when Obama took it from Bush,
he was making America great again.
You're talking about a shit show and the thing that people,
however you took it respected and not,
it was never nothing laced with anger.
It was never,
it wasn't no,
Yo,
you see this mess.
Bush left me.
It was never like,
oh this motherfucker
never no Michonne to see a new movie about Bush.
Do you see it?
I didn't see it either.
What's it called?
Jamie?
Is it out?
The one with vice vice?
Yeah,
Dick Cheney and George Bush.
Whenever I think about say a bucket,
the movie about getting shot in the face because that's the only thing that I
want to say.
Well the,
the,
the thing about Bush and Cheney is like that movie kind of makes it seem like
Cheney was the guy pulling the strings and Bush was just like simple,
happy go lucky guy who they just roped into being president because he was the
son of a president.
That's that far fetched though.
It's not far fetched at all.
It's not at all.
Not even remotely.
I think I actually agree with it.
When I think about Bush now,
I don't think about him in a negative way,
but I think about changing in a negative way.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
I think about cheating about it.
I think about Halliburton.
I think about all the rebuilding of the places that we blew up,
like all the crazy shit from Dick Cheney come from picture,
no bid contracts that are worth billions of dollars to.
You said
that in my the bush,
because if I ha,
I know it may sound crazy.
If I had to have a pick of who I would want it to be,
the Republican candidate it was on the Republican side was on.
I liked Jeb bush.
I didn't really get to know him at all.
That's it.
That was something that I don't know that I don't know too much about,
but I just,
I just thought that he had,
he was like kind of like a mama's boy.
I think he probably,
out of all kids,
I probably think that he probably was the one that thought a little outside of
what their normal is.
I think he was a successful businessman.
The Latino chicken if I'm not mistaken,
but I just,
I don't know.
But,
but Bush,
I mean Trump fucked him up.
Like,
Yo,
how do you fuck motherfuckers up with just nicknames wander to down.
It felt like jab wanted to lay down.
I really do.
I felt you didn't want to Trump put all the motherfuckers days like you were
safe until you get your nickname.
Yeah.
Once you got lion,
no g g jam.
You know that motherfucker.
They rap artists.
No,
it was a smart thing he did that no one's ever done before.
Nobody.
That's a lot of things.
And even like even when I'm,
even when Obama got elected,
you know what it got?
Obama elected was fucking Facebook and $5 contributions,
$5 donations.
He was when he was,
when?
When when an Obama was running that he was the first person to use Facebook the
way he did.
Really?
Oh Man.
They have so many every goddamn day.
It was Obama accident,
but he wouldn't ask for like millions.
He was just like,
like a dude in the hood.
Yo,
let me hold $5.
Right.
Like,
I would get an email,
hey,
this is Barack Obama,
Yo,
let me hold $10 right?
And I got s and I was like,
yeah,
here go $10 right?
And then a week later he asked for fucking $20 and then he asked for 10 again
and Vinny got so bad.
Then Michelle was sent me an email.
But he just,
he nickeled and dimed America.
And that's what supported his campaign and the fact that he was at right at the
turn of,
of,
uh,
of a form of media that you could use to your advantage.
He was the Facebook guy.
He reached people,
the Facebook,
Donald Trump's doing the same thing through Twitter.
I can reach people.
Why does he tweet so much?
Why does he tweet so much everyday?
Cause he knows motherfuckers would rather pick up a phone and read a treat.
Didn't read a newspaper 100%.
Fuck.
All I need is headlines.